for years years there have been as part
of our civilization special-purpose
electromechanical computers and classic
example of these is vending machines if
you put in the right combination of
money they will vend you a bar a chewing
gum or whatever and they've been around
for so long that they really are largely
mechanical they're a bit more
sophisticated now because they've got
microchips inside them but they don't
really need that we're going to look at
the fundamentals of vending machines or
if you like very similar how do I pay my
car park charge and get a ticket that I
put on my windshield and to say yes I
have paid what's the process of saying
you must pay me 25 P if you're in the UK
in the States you must pay me 25 cents
and I've got real live UK coins here
this is one of the simplest finite state
automaton examples I know of because I
think you'll all find it familiar here
in the UK if we're told we have to pay
25 P typically you would have to choose
from a 5 pence coin 10 pence coin a 20
pence coin
unlike the USA we do not have a 25 pence
coin you cannot just as it were put one
coin in and that's 25 and you're done
you've got and build it up out of any
possible combination of these and if you
look at this diagram with me it's it's
so simple it's just self explanatory you
start over here the machines got no
money in it
you put in one of these five P cones and
it goes drunk and it moves into what I
shall call the five state it basically
saying to yourself I'm happy I've got
five P so far but it's not enough yet
well alright let's be a controversial
let's make our second coin be a ten
pecan now we take this transition out of
the five state we've put in the ten coin
and it jet propels us into the fifteen
state so the machine if only I had a
brain is effectively smiling and saying
I'm on the way
fifteen P but the aim is 25
well does it two ways to get from
fifteen to twenty-five look you either
put two more fives in that gets you
there or one time and when you get to 25
I'll put it inside a double circle which
is the convention because that's the
finish that you've put in twenty five P
and eventually go bleep you and print
you out a ticket and because play 25 P
it's entitles you to two hours parking
or whatever all that this is doing is
encoding in this diagram all the
possible ways that you can build up 25 P
and if you think about it in a weird way
it's kind of like a language and the
sentences in the language are possible
ways to make up 25 P so here's a legal
sentence this is the other way to think
about it a legal sentence in this
language is five five five five five
another legal sentence just using the
words twenty and ten and five is 25
that's a legal sentence except 25 P how
about ten ten five are but then it could
be in any combination there's 10 10 5 5
10 10 10 5 10 5 5 5 10 works so you can
go through this if you want to work out
all of the many many combinations that
will you get 25 P it leaves you of
course with situations that what
happened
if you overpay you've only got three of
these ten pecans
30p many say if you overpay I don't mind
it's more profit for me and you know
I'll give you the ticket anyway some
badly designed ones just seized up and
sulk but then if they seized up and sulk
the question is in the end is there a
sort of reject button you can press
which says I've given you too much and
now give it all back to me or does it
just gobble it up and say I'm sorry it's
an illegal amount it's too much and I
won't print you a ticket
this gets people really really annoyed
when this happens but you all know the
symptoms of exactly the sort of thing
and like I'm saying these are so
commonplace they've been with us for
ages but the crucial thing I want to
emphasize is the following if you're
sitting there in the 15 state all that
this machine says or knows inside itself
if you like is I am in the 15 state if
you say to it but how did you get there
it would say I don't know I just don't
know I retain no memory of the coins
I've had to get me to this state at all
I just know I'm in 15 it could have been
10 and 5 going to me five five five who
cares
I'm in a 15 state so that is why these
are machines with no need for memory
there if you like a processing system
that accepts coins and you could perhaps
argue it is the ultimate special-purpose
computer
it's a special-purpose dumb computer
that vents tickets for a parking lot
only thing it does need is when you put
in a coin every single coin it needs a
holding position you could think of this
has been like a sort of register inside
a set of roses unit it holds the current
colleen and often will examine it and of
course in the early days all it could do
to check it with valid was maybe weigh
it nowadays you can shine lasers at them
do spectroscopic analysis and all sorts
to determine so the current coin is held
in I always think of it as a sort of
register to hold it until it's decided
to accept it
and when it's accepted it drops into a
pot of all the coins you've given so far
and maybe within the 15 state we get
another five we go into 20 but that
latest five just got chunk and you hear
it drop inside and it's in the pot but
the pot is amorphous the pot has no
knowledge of how those coins got in
there and in what order
it doesn't need to know that we've
taught us about vending machines we
talked about polymers is there anything
that they get used for in computer
science maybe that's more of a kind of
technical or coke yes yes vending
machines parking machines the simplest
thing and what you're asking is what's
the thing that really turns on computer
scientists that's that simple I'll tell
you Shawn what's that simple it's the
rules for what is a valid variable named
in a language now if you've done any
programming you will know that the rule
typically is a variable name an
identifier is a sometimes call can be
any combination of letters or digits in
any order but it must start with a
letter yeah so you can have Shawn Dave
they'll be variables you can say they're
integers or whatever you can even have
k9 as a thing but you can't have nine K
yeah because anything beginning with a
digit could be the start of a number and
what languages do not want to spend ages
deciding whether nine nine nine nine
really is meant to be a number or in
some way weird where you're trying to
name a variable Oh No if it starts with
a digit it's going to be a number isn't
there if it starts with a letter
it's an identifier or a variable name
and you can see with that you could draw
one of these diagrams you could say come
in is it a letter fine next aid is it a
letter fine go back recursively into
yourself and expect more letters or is
it a number loopback recursively into
yourself again you've got a self include
coming out back in again with letter on
the top of it and the loop at the bottom
saying digit on the
and you can keep going round and round
taking any combinations or letters or
digits until typically what happens is
you come to a sort of end symbol and in
a program what will happen of course is
you'll have a semicolon int Shan
semicolon that says that's the end of
the identifier or sometimes it'll be a
comma if you're declaring lots of things
but there's always some end symbol that
tells you end of identifier and shows
that legal you don't need any anything
fancy to recognize that that's illegal
identify you don't need stacks
you don't need tongues around it's just
one of these things for example here's
the table here's the floor where which
bits of the floor and which bits of this
table can I see so you have to do a lot
of matrix solving